welcome everybody to the town hall
bidford and those joining us on YouTube
to the September meeting meeting of the
plans committee there are no planned
fire drills for this morning so should
the alarm go off please leave the
building the way that you came in and do
not use the lift I would just like to
ask committee members to introduce
themselves by stating their name and the
ward that they represent and likewise
likewise can the officers introduce
themselves do if I can start with
councilor
he yep councelor heel I represent Milton
and Tamar side
good morning my name is Peter Christie I
represent bford North good morning I'm
Doug Smith I
represent
good good morning I'm Doug bushby and I
represent bford North and I'm also
substituting for Council of
penting good morning Steven Gibson I
represent broad Heath and I'm
substituting for Jane
whiter morning Council Chris leather and
I represent
new good morning Sandra committee
Clark morning Stacy Dory head of league
on governance my name is rosby lock and
I represent two rivers and three
Ms good morning I'm Helen Smith the
planning
manager Mary Ellen Wally planning
officer thank you chair apologies
councelor Whitaker councelor Gibson
substituting and um councelor Pennington
councelor bushby
substituting thank you item number two
to agree the minutes of the meeting held
20th of
July those minutes thank you seconded
all those in
favor
extensions
item number three Declarations of
Interest members with interest to
declare should refer to the agenda item
and this occasion by virtue of their
membership of that Council hold a
personal interest and are deemed to have
considered the application separately
and the express views of that council do
not bind the members concerned who
consider the application AR fresh which
may include further
information item number four agement
between Parts one and two we have no
part
twos item number five urgent matters I
have none but I will pass you on to the
planning
manager
yes1
92222 F which relates to Cherrywood Park
Business Center that application has
actually been withdrawn since the
virtual site visits last week so um that
that will not be for consideration this
morning okay
number public participation the order of
speaking is a a representative of the
town or Parish Council two members of
the public against and two members of
the public in support and all of the
above have three
minutes the W member may speak and they
are not limited to three minutes and I
will read out the names of those who
have who have registered to speak when
we come to that particular
application so item number seven moving
on the plan and
applications application 1 st05
7423 ground floor extension for 12
Pinkham road bford and it is on pages 12
to 17 of your agenda are there any
Declarations of
Interest none so the officer will now
give the presentation
please so this single story side
extension has been called before the
committee because the applicant is
related to staff members at
torage the site is located kind of
opposite cown at the end of a new um
housing estate circled there in
red and that shows you the property
that's accessed um along Sam's close and
then into Pinkham
Road
uh and there you can see the extent of
the property with the access driveway at
12 pinkin
road so the proposal is for a side
extension um measuring approximately 4
by 4 and a half MERS to the side of the
property that's a photo showing you um
in the foreground the access way that
goes to the left down to the property um
and the access from from the main road
um at the
back and that is the property there with
the uh Garage in a block with two
garages and it's the the property on the
left hand
side that's the front of the property
where the side extension is going to be
and the left hand side behind the close
boarded
fence this is the existing ground floor
plan of the property
um and you can see the the enclosed rear
Garden at the the top of the plan and
there's also a side Garden so the um the
extension will go to the side and will
be 4 M by 4 and A2
M and that's the front elevation
existing with a garage for a neighboring
property to the left hand
side
and that's the location of where the
extension will be behind that section of
close boarded
fence and that's showing what it will
look like using similar materials to the
existing property um with a pitched roof
and that's the rear elevation
existing and that's the rear elevation
of the uh the new extension with a
window to the rear elevation and as you
can see there's water butts on on the
front and the rear
elevation and that's the existing side
elevation that the um extension will
come
from and that's the side elevation with
the extension in place with a door to be
able to access um the
side in terms of the main planning
considerations the principle of
development it's um st6 it's within
bidford and it's a small extension so
complies with
dm25 in terms of character and
appearance it's similar to the existing
material and therefore complies with
dm25 and
dmo4 um private neighboring amenity
there are
no no second floor so it's just ground
floor there's one window to the rear and
that overlooks the private Amity space
of the dwelling
there's no changes to highways and
parking caused by the proposal and
therefore it's compliant with
the5 um drainage the surface water
drainage will Connect into the existing
with a soakaway within the rear Garden
um and with water butts to the front and
the rear of the
extension and it's a minor proposal and
therefore didn't trigger the need for a
wildlife report or any ecological
enhancement
therefore the recommendation is to Grant
approval for this
application thank you very much for the
presentation I have no public speakers
so I will open up the discussion yes
Council Christine I propose we accept
this it's only come before us because of
family connections hasn't it I mean
normally this would just get noted
through really so I I'll propose it so
it's been proposed by councelor Christie
seced by councelor he that the
application is
approved sorry recorded vote
sorry thank you chair councelor Christie
councelor Gibson four councelor hes
councelor heo four councelor leather
four councelor lock for councelor Smith
four councelor weekly four councelor BBY
four that's unanimous chair thank you
very
much so we now go on to the erection of
the summer house and the oranger sanct
lane bridge Rule and is on pages 34 to
41 of your agenda are there any items
Declarations of
Interest
none so the officer will now give the
presentation thank you chair uh the
application is for the change of use of
um land Within in close to Sanctuary
Lodge um and the addition of a summer
house/ orangery
um the there was an update for members
which was reflected in the this
discussion at site visit as well on the
next
slide which reflects the um change in
the red line um the original Red Line
application site was set on the left
hand side just surrounding the parcel of
land where the summer house would be
located ated um and now we've got the
revised one on the right hand side which
reflects the residential curtilage of
sanctuary Lodge itself uh and just sort
of shows the association between the
host dwelling and the
proposal we've got an aerial photograph
of the site so it's set to the southwest
of Village of bridge rule um and outside
of the settlement boundary so just shown
in the red box at the bottom
there um now I think members are some we
had some questions about sort of the
curtilage of the dwelling so just to
give a bit historic context to this this
was an application that we received and
approved in 2007 for um an side
extension to the main dwelling at
Sanctuary Lodge um so that indicates the
um Red Line residential curage at the
time included the driveway which comes
in from the southwestern Corner um sort
sweeps around and the and the area REM
immediately around the
property and then subsequently planning
history includes the next
slide with um there two applications
which were received in 2016 one was for
a sunro so sort of an infill extension
that you can see on the leftand plan
there um and then there was a further
one for a side extension which is
reflected on the second the next slide
um both included the same red line again
including the access
Drive uh and the sort of garden areas
immediately around the main
dwelling so just give members a little
bit of historic context and if we move
on to the next slide we've got um just
an aerial photograph version of sort of
the evolution of the site so in
2021 you can see there that the works
were being undertaken for the sort
of side extension sort of almost
semicircular um coming from the main
dwelling there um and the agricultural
buildings and main dwelling at Sanctuary
Lodge and then you can see in in 2018
the initial extension was already there
but again shows the relationship of the
application site that we're considering
now and the sighting of the summerhouse
which is on the southern side of the
access
drive and then just for some more
context we go back further in time got
2014 um and 2010 which just shows how
the management of the site has changed
over time and and how that southern
parcel of land has been used over
time so moving on to the application
plans um we're proposing a single story
summerhouse which is to be located to
the southwest of the main
dwelling um so we've
got the plan there which indicates an
access pathway coming from the main
Drive um and soak away which is
indicated just to the southeast and the
next slide I think shows that in a a
little more detail for
members so it'll be set within the
existing Hedges and boundaries of the
site and there's the proposed summer
house which would be Timber
clad um um include a veranda around two
sides of the
building and there's some cgis as well
there for just to give members an idea
as to how it may appear and then the
floor plan which confirms The Veranda
and decking area that would go around
the outside and um propos an internal
layout so move on to some site
photographs these some of these were
from our site visit last week but we've
also got some some further ones um which
we take in more recently in slightly
better weather um so the leftand
photograph um is of the access point
from the main public highway it's
looking into the site towards where the
summer house would be
positioned uh the right hand photograph
graph being shown is a view from where
the summer housee would be positioned
back across the access drive and down
towards the main
dwelling and then looking back along the
access drive back up to where the
summerhouse would be positioned adjacent
to the Hedge rows that you can see in
the
photograph and then a similar photograph
but from slightly closer up just to give
you an idea as to how the land's
currently
used
and just panning around to to show you
sort of the landscape views that you
gain from the application
site similar again so be looking looking
down across the uh the site and then
back towards the driveway and the
dwelling okay so the main plan material
planning considerations uh the principal
of
development the principal of the
proposed summer house in this location
is is the key issue um and as set out in
the office's report whilst the
provisions of policy dm25 provide an in
principal support for ancillary
development on residential sites this is
subject to their form scale setting and
design respecting existing development
its context setting and surroundings I
think that's set out within the
officer's Report with particular
reference to supporting texts to the
policy at paragraph 13
.36 uh the proposed summer house would
be located at a distance of between 40
and 50 Metter from the main dwelling and
outside of the defined residential
curtilage uh no justification has been
provided for the building to be located
at this distance from the main dwelling
and the associated need for the change
of use of land to residential given the
surrounding application sites so the
principle of the proposed development is
considered to be contrary to the
provisions of policy St 7 setting out
the rural strategy for the district and
policy
dm25 um secondly the character and
appearance as set out in the officer's
report the proposed summer house is not
considered to result in a substantial
impact on the wider landscape given its
modest scale and the development would
be in keeping with the provisions of the
local plan in that
regard in terms of amenity um given the
citing of the development in relation to
neighboring properties no harmful impact
is considered to result on neighboring
amenities with drainage a provision
would be made within the plans for
surface water drainage to be via
soakaway to the southeast of the
summerhouse um and the development is
acceptable in this
regard uh highways and parking we would
make use of the existing access and
parking Provisions so no objections are
are raised in that respect and in terms
of ecology the proposed summer house and
change of use of the land is not cons
consider to result in a harmful impact
on protected species so the proposed
development is recommended for refusal
for the single reason which is set out
on page 41 of your agenda thank you
chair thank you Laura our first rant
speaker is Mr Gareth
short Mr Gareth short is not
that so our second regant speaker is the
W member of councilor Ken
James
[Applause]
thank you chair I just apologize for G
short he did say to me what time last
night and I said a p 10ish so um I was
still under the impression there was two
on the agenda before once again I just
find myself here trying to defend the
rights of the rural community um uh
sightly disappointed I'm going to keep
doing it um that we we yesterday as most
you know I should have gone to London
but it's a long sad story of how we got
stuck in a traffic jam missed the train
and then the minister was poorly to
defend the fact that we're a deprived
area and yet our economy is based
primarily on the rural um economy which
uh North Devon plus last week we had a
really good presentation telling us how
it's going into sh sharp decline on this
particular I remember when it was just a
fall in D Barn it's a credit to the
applicant the way that he's transformed
it he's heavily into ecology and uh tree
planting he runs a very successful
Sawmill business that used to be at
Brandis Corner which is no adic site and
he's on he's based in marfield in the
middle of my farm which has nothing to
do with the application um and
he makes a major contribution to the
community in that um I suspect he will
build his own summer h house um and I
would have like to have seen the plan to
that and i' be straight with you all
that I have expressed that for you but
he's recently just built a poly poly
tunnel and supplied the material and
built it for the primary school which
his two do Grand his two daughters
attend um and he's got a very split
family and two girls that were had a
very difficult start in life twin girls
that are still at primary school as far
as I'm concerned it doesn't distract
from the area at all it's positioned
where it is because in his discussions
with the property behind um The
Sanctuary they expressed The View that
they like looking over his um little
Asis and looking at the river Tamar so
the sting was agreed with them rather
than what the applicant originally was
going to do so on that respect and the
other interesting thing and I was glad
it came up you may may not have noticed
on one of the slides showing the site
there's a huge crane in the background
and they are currently building a
massive sewer plant for bridge Ru
because we've expanded so much over the
years so it is not the last thing
extending out into the country isues
with it any with it and so that's all I
want to say at this moment thank you
chair right there's no further speakers
so I will throw the matter open for
discussion who'd like to kick off
uh thank you chair um yeah I carried out
a site a physical side inspection on
last Friday the 1st of September um and
it it is clear now from the photographs
um that were taken during my site visit
that it is um it appears to be a garden
area it's a lawn um there's no I think
the officer has referred to it as um uh
as being part roughly half of a wider
enclosed Pedic well it's not enclosed at
all it's it's open it's it's enclosed on
three sides but on the road side the
access Drive side it's completely open
um here in terms of how long it's been
in uh as it as it is appears to be a
gardenary I it's not enclosed on any of
those is
it it's enclosed on three sides but not
the not the driveway side and logic
would dictate to me that it it's it's
it's a part of the Garden area already
it's it's the only amenity lawn area
safe for anybody
to children in particular to to play in
we got a pond further down um I'm I'm
just rather surprised that uh it's
actually the the area defined in the red
line is actually only half of that
lawned area
logic would dictate that it's actually
should be the whole of that
area um there's no objections at
all um I I I can't I can't it the it's a
subjective view as to whether it it is
it is uh contrary to the the policies I
think um it doesn't appear to be
contrary to dm25 as far as I can
see it's not uh it's not an Annex it's a
summer house I don't know why it's
described as an oranger because it's not
an orange Tre at all it's just a summer
house and I I cannot see any problem I I
would um recommend
approval bearing in mind that you have
to have planning reasons for
approval well I think the is it is it
not a subjective view that the planning
officer has expressed there well if if
you read the the officer's reports he
does say that it Accords with some of
the policies st4 dm4 dm8 dm25 dmo1 st3
dm2 dmo5 dm6 st14 and dm8 and all those
policies the officers Accords with well
it says the proposal is therefore
considered to be contribute to polies
st7 dm25 and N
ndlp so it's bit contradictory yeah
any other
comments yes Captain
zes um yes um I take the point that uh
the property the looks like it's a
garden but
nevertheless um the objective fact is
that it's um outside the residential
curtilage as I understand it offic
report so putting that aside I was just
wanting to ask about the
the councelor James sort of indicated
that the ACT might build it himself my
imp I think that's what you said anyway
my impression is that it will be a
standard design and that was the final
design but just clarify that and also do
we know that the um layout inside
doesn't actually indicate what's going
to go inside do we know any more about
that can I ask for you chair
well again I think in the officers
report the applicant has stated that
there will be no bedrooms or kitchen
within the
property it just doesn't indicate on the
layout what it will be really but there
we
are I
did I mean I would like to ask the
planning manager if it was approved
could we
condition that the um Som house would
not be used for any residential purposes
could be condition
that so yeah ju answering chair your
point first um yeah certainly a
condition could be put on that it's um
used as an on an anciliary basis to the
named dwelling which is the the address
of the application so that certainly
could be done um on on the point of the
the design and
clarification the committee has to
consider what's what's before them and
these are the drawings and the plans
that are before the the committee for
consideration today if something
different does come forward um that
could potentially
require another application if if it's
if it's broadly the the same then you
know I I doubt there would be an issue
around that but you have to sort of
decide what's before what's before for
you
today um and yeah I I don't know whether
it' be helpful for the case officer just
to pick up on some of the the comments
around the internal layout and um the
the policy basis or the presenting
officer should I
say um the internal layout is as per the
plans um so we've got of a summerhouse
use um and it sort of indicated it's for
use sitting in the garden um we haven't
got any indication there that there
would be any bathroom facilities or
kitchen facilities which would result in
it being used as either an Annex or
something that's more
self-contained um and certainly as I
think councilor lock indicated it it set
out in the officer's report that the
applicant has clarified that I think on
page 38 says the applicant has also
confirmed the building would not have
kitchen bathroom or any sleeping
arrangements so we are considering a
floor plan such as
that ccil leather
thank you chair well I I'm happy to
Second councelor he's recommendation to
approve it
because uh the application as it says on
the for is for part of that land which
currently is looked on as being
agricultural to be change of view of the
land to domestic so it's not all that
piece of land just the where the red
line is where they want to site the
summerhouse so if we accept that that
can be changed to domestic use and
looking at the overall side I can't
think there's anywhere else where you'll
be able to put this this um summer house
there's no proper green outside space
apart from this and I think as councelor
heo said and he he's actually been on
the site it um it does look as if it's
part of the the whole site anyway I mean
we can condition it that it's ancillary
to Sanctuary Lodge and the occupants of
sanuy Lodge we I would like to see a
condition that there's a Poston rail
fence following that red line across
that field or grass area there so that
does delineate that's part of the
domestic curs it doesn't affect anybody
else I mean st7 is quoted and S and dm25
well dm25 speaks about ancillary
development um
the foreman scale there's three things
Foreman scale and setting and design of
The Proposal respecting existing
development its context settings and
surroundings it does that adequate
residential immunity space and parking
provision being maintained that that's
true there being no significant adverse
impact on the immunity of the occupant
of neighborhood properties there isn't
so I don't know why why dm25 has been
quoted as a reason for refusal to be
honest um so for those reasons and I
also made a couple of notes about the
retention of
EX and it's purely for the domestic use
of that
property you know I mean we haven't got
a policy anywhere and I don't think most
local planning authorities have where
you've got a policy that says common
sense
you know I they don't exist but but
we've got to we've got to deal with it
as a piece of agricultural land the the
applicant wants part of it to now be
part of the domestic curtilage of fine I
got no problem with that nobody's any
problem with that and I don't really
know why planning officers would have a
problem with that well know it's like I
said earlier on I mean the officer says
that it called several um when I first
saw this I thought it must be really
sunny in bridg um they got a huge Sun
Lounge now they want a summer house as
well uh must be a different climate to
up here um can I just say one thing I'm
not I'm not being personal here but
councelor James talked about the rights
of the rural community I'm not sure they
extend to putting up you know the odd
building here and there without planning
um and
also if we are going to
have uh Ward members come along and
speak speak they councilors need to be
aware of that um but having said that
and listen to the arguments I think I
will vote in favor I was in two minds to
start but I think I looked at I've got
this on Google Earth I'm looking at it
and it does seem as though it's quite
clearly related to the building I think
so I've got no problem with
it any further comments if not it has
been proposed by yeah um it would be
helpful to have conditions as part of
that recommendation would it help if I
suggest some some conditions for you
members um so we would look to always
include the Standard Time condition a
plans condition the ancillary use or
linked to the dwelling and not as an
independent residential unit um a a a
preoccupation or pre-c coming into use
condition requiring a boundary treatment
that that corresponds with the area
that's subject to the change of use um
councel you did mention around sort of
protection of the Hedge
rows this sort of scale and type of
development it's unlikely there would be
an impact on on those hedge rows would
would be my view but it is open to
members to include something along those
lines if they wish you like that
included yeah I that's still
includ retention of Hedges and
existing
okay I think that that's probably it and
within the report it also mentions
domestic paraphernalia and that includes
things like picnic tables and barbu
could we include that in the condition
or is that OT I think if you're
accepting the change of use of that land
to domestic purposes um it would it
would be slightly contrary to then not
want any of that assoc I think that harm
is being accepted by you as a committee
um I I think you know as as part of the
recommendation it it it needs to be made
clear why it's considered to be in
accordance with policy
st74 so the the correct interpret
application of that policy you know the
the case officer has made that that
correct judgment um we we are sort of
Duty bound to protect the countryside
and um only development that's
necessarily restricted to a Countryside
location however the the discussion and
debate today um has put put forward the
position that that that members feel
that there's limited harm to this and it
play performs a strong um relationship
to that host dwelling so I think it's
just to to be clear as to why you think
that that it's it's acceptable in terms
of st7 so are we all happy with those
conditions so it has been proposed by
councelor he or seconded by councelor
leather that the application is approved
so we now go to the
vote thank you chair councelor Christie
councelor Gibson councelor hes councelor
heppo four councelor leather councelor
lock four councelor Smith councelor
Wheatley councelor bushby that's
unanimous chair thank you very
[Applause]
much right going back to your agenda
that is the end of the app app pages 42
to
87 any comments on
those yes
Captain I like because we are getting
more and
clearly they
areay a lot
money you know it's the Africans need to
be aware
I was going to raise the same point and
I was going to even ask have we
submitted an amount
yet yeah Ju Just to update on that we
we're currently working through um what
that cost claim should entail so it's it
as as the appeal um it does involve
getting sort of
it it does involve getting sort of a lot
of different elements of the council it
it was a te sort of council service wide
input so we had our legal team played
quite a role in this as well so we're
still we're still pulling that claim
together but I would envisage we will
have something um ready to to to send
the applicant or the appellant should I
say in in the next sort of one to two
weeks but it will include the the full
cost of of the Barrister that was that
was appointed and I do agree with coun
Christie that you know members of the
public should be made
aware but I don't know quite how you do
that yeah we we we can certainly look at
that with um with our our Communications
team and and with the senior management
team it's the best the best way of item
number nine up and highlighting that you
know people go to a think oh well I can
at least I'll go to rep with it even
when there's no chance them succeed in
the appeal and I think once it is all
settled and as the planning manager says
uh the bill will go to the applicant
then it's got to be argued over and once
it's agreed it should be published then
that an applicant that on spurious
reasons went to appeal or was found to
be spous as cost awarded against them I
meaning it's just a is a warning to
people isn't it not not to do it in a
flippant manner
yeah yeah um absolutely councelor
leather and I think we we will we will
discuss with the appropriate sort of
teams within the council around that and
just on the appeal decisions I think
yeah I'd just quite like to highlight I
think as was recognized by by Council
Christie all of the appeals that are in
your on your agenda today have all been
dismissed so um and they are a
combination of committee and officer
decisions so I think that's incredibly
encouraging um shows that that we as a
council are making good Rec B decisions
um against our current policies we we
have included enforcement appeal